a bordo de este vehículo un equipo
médico en la media luna roja afgana se
dirige a las ciudades remotas del país
donde no hay infraestructura sanitaria
me duele el ojo está rojo no solo está
hinchado podría verlo no
estás estar que nunca vuelven aseguró
según la tradición local no estoy
autorizado a ver su rostro así que no
puedo ver su ojo en el hospital podemos
examinar a las mujeres pero aquí no sólo
puedo darle medicina según los síntomas
que me describen
un perro mordió a este niño hace tres
días cada dos meses estos lugareños
reciben visitas médicas
la mayoría de la gente no tiene los
medios para ir al hospital porque está
muy lejos
si nuestro equipo no viniera aquí
recurrirían algunos remedios
tradicionales que pueden ser peligrosos
en la sala contigua una enfermera revisa
a las mujeres embarazadas muchas de
ellas darán a luz a solas en sus casas
la mortalidad materna es alta porque no
tienen acceso a los centros de salud y
los esposos no permiten que sus mujeres
vean a un médico hombre como mujer puedo
ir a revisarlas incluso en sus casas así
que se alegran de verme el sistema
sanitario es muy precario este hospital
único en el país está especializado en
kobe 19 no ha recibido ninguna
financiación desde hace varias semanas
aunque el personal sanitario no ha sido
remunerado este médico sigue trabajando
estos pacientes se encuentran en estados
muy críticos sus pulmones se han
deteriorado entre 90 y 95 por ciento
todo el oxígeno que se les está es a
través de ventiladores si no fuera por
estas máquinas habríamos perdido la
mayoría de estos pacientes a los equipos
médicos de este hospital lo rural les
preocupa la posible suspensión de la
financiación internacional cada día el
centro recibe 500 pacientes de los
pueblos aledaños muchos sufren de
desnutrición
esto sucede por la deficiencia de
proteínas no es así para las personas
sanas nos dijeron que el actual contrato
de financiación sólo duraría dos meses
si se suspende la financiación del
sistema sanitario colapsará acá porque
este hospital como la mayoría de los
centros de salud pública afganistán
depende al 100 por ciento de la ayuda
internacional